good afternoon
i'm here today with alberta's chief
medical officer of health dr hinshaw to
provide an update on coven 19 in the
province
currently the number of lab confirmed
active cases is nineteen thousand and
fifty
that's down by more than two thirds from
the peak of seventy one thousand that we
saw on january sixteenth
and virus levels in our wastewater
monitoring continue to drop as we'll see
in a moment these are signs we want to
see
as we
start our first week with no mandatory
masking for children and youth in
schools
of course we respect the rights of
children youth and their parents and
guardians to make their own choices
we're balancing the current risk of
covet transmission in schools while
supporting overall mental health and
physical well-being for students
and a reminder there's one thing
everyone can do to lower their risk and
the risk to their kids
and that's to get vaccinated and get
their children vaccinated
starting today
youth who who are immunocompromised or
have an underlying health condition can
book appointments for booster doses of
coven 19 vaccine
dr hinshaw will have more details in a
moment
but i know this is welcome news to
parents and guardians who are doing all
they can to protect their children
we're moving forward based on the
evidence and balancing the risks to the
health system with the cost and harms
from restrictions
this balance has guided our decisions
from the start of the pandemic and it as
it has in other jurisdictions
the approach has not changed but the
pandemic has changed and so has the data
here in alberta
canada's chief medical officers of
health see the same data
and in their statement yesterday
they agree the evidence supports
rebalancing our efforts towards a more
sustainable approach to the long-term
management of kovid
when and how this will happen will vary
province province but it's time to begin
this transition
and the majority of albertans agree with
this view
a recent poll found that 57 percent of
albertans support removing restrictions
this week another poll says it's
two-thirds of albertans
and the same transition is happening
around the world and across the country
just yesterday ontario accelerated their
reopening
every day other jurisdictions of every
political stripe are making similar
decisions based on the same evidence
so let's take a moment to look at where
we're at here in alberta
one of the leading indicators of copen
19 levels is the signal we see in the
wastewater
using that data we could start to see
the shape of omicron wave about six
weeks ago
in edmonton the wastewater signal peaked
on january third but of course we didn't
know that at the time we had to wait and
let the data show the shape of the curve
by about three weeks ago we could see
that the wave was passing
this pattern is similar in calgary but
even more pronounced
and to show you how strong this trend
can be the next slide shows banff
it's the clearest picture of all the 19
sites where we have data
it's an interesting example because
there's so much movement back and forth
between banff and calgary so it peaked
right after calgary did
bath has a young and active population
with a lot of contact and unfortunately
a relatively low vaccinate vaccination
rate in younger adults
this graph shows the distinct omicron
pattern up very fast and down just as
quickly
and one other critical point
the fact that the level is so low
doesn't mean it will stay low
this wave was brought into band by
visitors just as kovit overall was
brought into alberta from outside
it can come in again
in fact we should assume it will
but right now the level is falling fast
waste water levels and case data are
leading indicators they help show when
the risk is going up or down over the
next few weeks
but the risk we have to manage the basis
for our restrictions is the burden on
our health care system
based on the surge in virus levels and
our experience in previous waves we
prepared for a wave of hospital
emissions that would have the potential
of disrupting our system
going into the omicron wave
we kept restrictions largely in place
from the delta wave and in fact we
increased them
but the pandemic changed
the wave of excess emissions that we
were prepared for is not happening
and there currently is no basis for
us to expect them that wave of
hospitalizations to happen
so as soon as that was clear
we made the decision to move forward and
to ease restrictions
the number of patients in our non-icu
hospital units remains within their
normal capacity and in line with mid
winter levels
before covid
over the past week there have been
around fifty two hundred to fifty four
hundred non-icu patients in total
on sunday there were five thousand two
hundred and fifty
that's an occupancy rate of
approximately ninety percent of the
normal pre-covered capacity in those
units
and it's lower than the number of
patients in those same units in january
of every year from 2015 to 2019 before
covid
the level in those years range from
about 5400 to 5600.
vaccination changed the pandemic
a third to half of covent emissions are
now incidental
so the number of coveted positive
patients in hospital doesn't mean what
it did just a few months ago
and length of stay has dropped so the
average admission today means less
burden on the hospitals than a few
months ago but i want to be clear
the people who work in our hospitals are
still under strain
we owe them a huge debt of gratitude and
more than that they need relief and they
need to get back to working in more
normal conditions
covid has not gone away it's still
causing severe illness and death
especially in the oldest and most
vulnerable people and people who are not
yet vaccinated
but at a system level the current wave
is not causing hospital emissions in
excess of the levels we would see in a
normal winter
the number of covet patients in our
hospitals has been on a downward trend
since february the seventh
it's dropping and it should continue to
drop in the coming weeks because new
admissions have fallen almost every day
for the past three weeks
they peaked at about 36 per million
population on january the 26th and on
sunday the rate was 24.
one third lower
so again the data has changed
just in the past couple of weeks
starting about two weeks ago it looked
like we had passed the peak in
admissions but we had to wait to be sure
now we can see it
new admissions are trending down and the
number in hospitals are trending down as
well
and that's in line with other
jurisdictions
in ontario for example the number in
hospital began a sustained decline about
a week after new daily admissions
started to drop steadily
we're on a similar curve
a couple weeks behind them
that's the core evidence behind our
reopening
it's the same evidence other
jurisdictions are following in making
the same types of decisions
i want to emphasize
the reopening plan depends on these
trends continuing
if they don't we'll take action as
necessary including reimposing
restrictions if we have to
and our success in keeping covert at bay
ultimately depends
on following the orders of our chief
medical officer of health and on
vaccinations
we need to keep working hard to get more
albertans vaccinated including third
doses
second doses for younger kids and third
doses for kids at higher risk
more than ever we must be vigilant about
our health
get vaccinated and if you get stick
say home
if we work together to keep each other
safe through this transition period i
have no doubt we will come through it
successfully
thank you and i'll now invite dr hinshaw
to give her update
thank you minister
and good afternoon everyone
i just inhaled some water so
excuse me
before i get to the data update i want
to provide information on a change being
made today to eligibility for early
covert treatment for those at risk of
severe outcomes
we have seen that a single dose of
vaccine is not protecting people against
severe outcomes as well as two or three
doses
so beginning today anyone 55 or older
who is unvaccinated or has only had a
single dose of vaccine
would be eligible for early treatment
with either paxlovid
or cetrovimab
this means that individuals in this
group who have even mild symptoms should
access pcr testing as soon as possible
so if they are positive they can be
referred for a conversation with a
health care provider on available
treatments to lower their risk of severe
outcomes
this is also true of anyone 18 years old
and over who has a clinical risk
condition like diabetes or heart disease
and has either no vaccines or a single
dose of a two dose series
finally anyone 18 or older who has a
significant immunocompromising condition
like having had a transplant or being on
active cancer treatment
is also eligible for early treatment
even if they have received all doses of
vaccine
over the last 24 hours we have
identified 838 new cases of covid19 and
completed about 2
500 tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases is about 33.9 percent
turning to hospitalizations there are
currently a total of 1
538 people with covet 19 in hospital
including 123 in the icu
sadly 14 new deaths were reported to
alberta health over the past 24 hours
while i know we are all tired of hearing
about kovid
the reality is that it continues to
cause severe outcomes and it is
important that we factor this into our
daily routines
my condolences are with the loved ones
of the people who have died
and with anyone in alberta who has lost
someone important to them no matter the
cause
as of today only two of the more than 2
500 schools in alberta are in temporary
at-home learning to address operational
challenges
alberta education will continue to work
with school authorities on school shifts
to at-home learning it is encouraging to
see a continuing declining trend
less than one tenth of one percent of
schools are now on temporary at home
learning
school authorities continue to have the
flexibility to shift a class or an
individual grade to short-term at-home
learning to address operational
challenges at schools if needed
as the minister mentioned vaccine
appointment bookings opened today for
third doses in the primary series for
children between the ages of 5 and 11
who have specific significant immune
compromising conditions
and third dose boosters for youth age 12
to 17 who have underlying health
conditions
or are first nations metis or inuit
as well adolescents between the age of
12 and 17 with immunocompromising
conditions can now receive a fourth dose
booster to help increase their
protection from covid19
if you were wondering if your child is
eligible for an additional dose i
encourage you to review the list of
conditions
at alberta dot ca vaccine or speak to
your health care provider
appointments can be booked online or
through the alberta vaccine booking
system or by calling 811.
the province is now in a period of
transition as we begin to shift from a
pandemic response to an endemic one this
is a shift all provinces are undertaking
as the minister mentioned a joint
statement by all chief medical officers
of health across canada was issued
yesterday
highlighting the beginning of a move
across the country to transition towards
an endemic phase of covid19
after nearly two years of requirements
to modify the way we have lived worked
and socialized to help reduce
transmission of the virus and protect
each other it's going to take time and
effort to adjust away from mandates and
towards personal risk assessments and
actions
for some albertans this transition will
seem quick and easy
for others it will be much more
challenging
and for many people it will likely be
somewhere in between
there is no one right way to respond to
these changes so we should expect
different responses
every person's experience through the
pandemic has been unique depending on
the challenges they have faced
coveted risk to individuals and the
population is not a binary on off or yes
no state
some people will continue to be at high
risk individually of having a severe
outcome should they be infected
as a population we will continue in the
short term to be impacted by the coveted
patient load on hospitals which is being
managed capably by healthcare teams but
is not yet back to a baseline state
also both as individuals and together as
a population we have all had impacts in
our lives from the protective measures
that have been necessary to use
throughout our various ways
as we move forward it will be vital that
we find a way to respect each other's
previous experiences comfort levels and
risk context
different as they may be from our own
this includes seeking to understand and
provide space for actions of others
especially if they are taking different
precautions than the ones we are taking
i particularly want to thank parents and
educators for their work to support our
kids to make a transition to a masking
optional school approach that started
yesterday
this change is hard
and our kids need us to support them and
to model how to respect others despite
differences
masking remains a very prudent public
health measure and those who are wearing
masks need to be supported
those who are no longer wearing masks
also need support so this single issue
does not further drive wedges in our
communities
in general i ask that all of us strive
to be mindful of the fact that we don't
know what factors are driving the
decisions of those around us
if you're not sure what someone is
comfortable with please don't assume
instead ask them and respect their
choices
this can apply to everything from
considering whether to plan gatherings
indoors or outdoors
asking about masking preferences when in
other people's homes
and planning for the upcoming return to
the workplace in ways that respect and
consider different levels of risk in
those who are impacted by change
one thing covit has shown us time and
time again
is how connected we are all to each
other and how our actions impact those
around us
as we move through this time of
transition
i ask that all of us stay mindful of
that fact and that we think of others as
well as ourselves as we go about our
daily lives
over the last few days i have heard some
reports of people refusing to wear masks
in public settings
i want to remind albertans that until we
are in step two masking is required in
indoor places across the province
masking is especially important in
health care settings
health care is different from other
public places and ahs and other health
care providers will continue to have
additional measures and precautions in
acute care and continuing care
facilities to help protect vulnerable
patients and residents
these measures are also keeping health
care workers safe
i ask all albertans who may need to
access any health care facility in the
coming weeks to be respectful of the
rules in place even if they're different
from other settings
by doing so you are helping to keep
patients residents and staff in these
facilities safe
finally i want to let you know about
plans for media availabilities over the
next few weeks
my team has tried over the last two
years to support the importance of
personal well-being and self-care for
those working on the response
as part of this we have been working
recently to set up a rotation of time
away from work and it is now my
opportunity to have some time off
after this week i will be away for two
weeks
minister copping will provide regular
covet updates to media during that time
and my team will continue to monitor the
data and provide input on the response
there will also not be a covered media
availability this thursday
thank you and we're happy to take
questions thanks dr hinshaw and minister
no one in the room here so we'll go
straight to the phone first caller
please
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there my question is for the health
minister um when you and the premier
outlined the public health measure
changes last week the premier said that
changes were based on trends in other
countries where omicron had emerged
before it had in alberta and had peaked
before it did in alberta the uk for
example we're now seeing many schools in
the uk are bringing mass back for kids
are you worried this is something that's
going to have to happen here as well
even though it was just dropped
yesterday
yeah not at this time what we're seeing
generally in a number of those countries
uk
and also we see in trends in ireland
that
the numbers are still trending down in
terms of both hospitalizations uh and
actually in terms of cases trending down
or maybe plateaued a little bit but
we're going to continue to watch it very
closely and and as i said before if we
need to make adjustments we will but
we're going to watch our own data and we
haven't seen
um a spike in hospitalizations in those
countries
thanks minister i'm matt follow-up
uh that's it for me today thank you
there's a first uh thanks matt so we'll
go to the next caller please
thank you jennifer lee cbc
hi thanks for taking uh my question and
this kind of dovetails off uh the
question you just had
you know there is a lot of concern about
the decision to lift
masking in schools
a number of physicians pediatricians
infectious disease folks
you know they're worried about the
implications of this decision
with only roughly about 20 of kids in
that five to 11 year old age range with
two doses so how do you respond to their
concerns that this is too early that it
could lead to increased transmission
followed by increased hospitalizations
and and how do you respond to their
calls to reinstate that math mandate or
requirement in school
yeah as we indicated last week when we
made the announcement you know we did an
assessment on a variety of uh of
measures recognizing that
the trends were heading in the right
direction hospitalizations as we as
shown earlier today uh new
hospitalizations have been dropping
steadily
and so we took a look at what are all
the measures in place uh look at the
measures that that you know may be less
effective or potential for for causing
harm so the rep uh we remove that as as
sort of phase one but also in regards to
masking and masking for for children
there's you know mixed evidence on the
uh on the efficacy and you know concerns
being raised about you know impacting
child learning
so
this was our first stage
we
put a program in place in terms of
reducing restrictions at a very stage
approach so we can actually watch what
happens over the uh the next couple of
weeks i understand some of the concerns
uh you know raised by uh by parents
there's different degrees of of comfort
levels as indicated by dr
dr henshaw we are in a transition phase
uh some people are
you know willing and eager to uh
to move forward and others are are
concerned we need to be respectful of
individual choices but now's the time to
make the transition move to individual
choices by uh by parents and uh and
their children and then we'll watch the
data
thanks minister uh jen follow up
yeah i do thanks i i think one of the
concerns you know
that we're hearing is that
first of all the the
the mask requirement is being lifted but
also that it's not being done in tandem
with other
uh measures that might sort of
compensate for that for example um
trying to address that low vaccination
rate among kids through things like
making vaccines more accessible in
different places so you know some of the
things i've heard is suggestions about
um you know making them available in
schools which i i know you've done with
the older kids
even after hours for example we're
hearing calls about
allowing family doctors offices to
provide them more pharmacies and even
places where kids go often places like
hockey rinks things like that so
what is the uh your government's
intention in terms of trying to make
this vaccine more accessible and if you
could comment on sort of each of those
types of locations that we're hearing
calls for the province to make them
available if you don't mind
no no thanks for the question no there
are some measures that remain in schools
as you know
cohorting for example uh those remaining
schools in regards to vaccinations
government we agree that vaccinations
are the the
uh the best
way to protect all of us and it's not
only about coming out of omicron
although that's that's you know the
numbers are coming down and we are on
the the other side of the fifth wave but
it's also protecting against future
waves and quite frankly we have to
normalize vaccines um to be able to like
covet vaccines just like everyone gets
the annual flu vaccine we may very well
need to be moving to that um now whether
it's an annual or every six months we'll
have to wait and see
you know my focus and we appointed a uh
an advisory committee on vaccination uh
to be able to provide uh advice to our
government and to to myself about how do
we improve uh vaccination rates at kids
it's just uh roughly uh 46 percent
um
for uh five to 11 year olds uh at this
point in time we need to get that higher
so we're looking at other options in
terms of doing that but when we talked
originally about
vaccines at school
when we did that for older older kids it
wasn't very successful in terms of the
rate but but again we'll we'll take a
look at our the various different
approaches over the coming weeks to be
able to support vaccine vaccination
because this is going to be with us for
a long time just like people who get flu
vaccines will likely need to get coveted
vaccines
thanks minister uh turns out we only had
two reporters waiting on the phone and
no one else so that's it we'll wrap it
up there uh thanks minister and thanks
dr hinshaw thank you